foreign
[Music]
we try to think about the floor
of course naturally
[Music]
I have gotten used to being one of the
leaders in my last job I was determined
to build up the same position at work
that's how the coffee machine works this
is how the blinds work
whenever anyone looked at me I fired off
a broad smile
a smile disarms your opponent and makes
them doubt their own enmity I stuck to
my schedule when I first discovered the
room
there was something special about this
place
answer me truthfully what is this room
for don't drag me into this I found a
secret room and when I work in there I'm
able to do anything a secret room it's
just that most people aren't able to see
it
were you on drugs
what are you doing when you stand like
that
what are you talking about
handy what that's about it's very
strange I say fire him if he's allowed
to stand there like that then I should
be allowed to practice Reiki in the
break area
there is no room Austin didn't I tell
you it was pointless to try and conduct
psychological warfare against me you
have secrets hidden in there that for
whatever reason you don't want me to see
but he's mental anyone can see that
I did try to warn you I must insist that
you stop going to it
you're different from the other people
here I can tell person you want to tell
me how far in advance all of this worked
out was I even one of the original
intended victims what exactly is it that
you want I just want to do my job I
don't care about you you're a number in
a column on a spreadsheet I could view
the world as something ominous or
I could choose to see the light
I chose to see the light
[Music]